angela what's going on i have an 11 year
old daughter who is in competitive
gymnastics
um we spend a lot of time and money
doing this and my husband and i are not
seeing
i guess the level of effort we would
like to see from her and we're kind of
just wondering how to go about
approaching that with her and if there
is a time to say
we're done or if we need to let her make
that choice
you are the only parents in the united
states of america having this problem
right now
i just want you to feel isolated and
alone in this okay
thank you thank you wow okay
so for a few minutes can i make this all
about me
and walk you through my situation
i promise i'll come back to you okay
okay there is nothing more annoying than
somebody being like hey will you help me
with something and i
and they respond with sure let me tell
you about my life um
okay so i'm gonna preface this with this
i am exhausted and annoyed by the
quote-unquote passion conversation
right i worked at universities for so
long
and i would get these 18 and 19 year
olds that would say i want to be
a singer or a guitar player i'm just so
passionate about it
i want to be a doctor i'm so passionate
about the medical field
here's the thing you become passionate
about what you love and you love what
you're good at
and you're good at what you practice and
unless you're an oddball
like my wife you practice what you were
made to practice as a kid right okay you
had to go through this
because you learn how to practice and
learn how to stick with something right
so that's my overall disclaimer and then
i'm gonna get personal
in eighth grade i was i've been this big
since i was like seven
okay so in eighth grade i was not a
great football player but i was pretty
fast
and at the end of the year i told my
parents hey we move up to high school i
went to a super 5a high school in texas
i think my high school had
three four thousand kids it was a lot
it's a big place
and i told my parents i don't want to
play
and my dad said you have to play you got
to go one more year
and i want you to give it your best so i
did at the end of that year
i said hey i want to be done with this
this leveled up here in high school it's
a much more competitive it's a
there's a bajillion kids out here and i
don't want to do it
and the next season my mom said you're
going to do it
you're going to stick it out one more
year that next year
i began to grow into my body some
i found some significant success i found
some great coaches that poured into my
life i found some great teammates
and that started a love affair with the
sport
i became a two-year player on varsity
got some extraordinary experiences that
i never would have had
more importantly i learned how to be
coachable
i learned how to not take things
personally but how to change my
behaviors
i still exercise to this day using some
of the techniques
and practices that i learned back when i
was in high school right
so i am a product of parents who would
not let me quit
now here's the other side my wife was a
just a a phenom at basketball
as a freshman she was a stud they were
having conversations
about playing on varsity and she was
just she was really good
and in her words i had to get out of
there
i had to quit and i asked her recently
hey
did you ever wish your parents made you
stay like because i'm a product if my
parents wouldn't let me bail out
and she said it would have ended
tragically for all of us if i'd stayed i
had to get out
and she ended up transitioning over
cross country where again she met a
great team
great great comrades she learned how to
work hard and all that stuff so why do i
say it like that here's the thing um for
my parents
they weren't living through me they saw
that i was a better human when i had
discipline
accountable accountability and extreme
physical exertion right they saw that
when i wasn't
playing sports when i wasn't running
around when i wasn't in a disciplined
environment
i was an idiot i was a bonehead in fact
one time my junior senior year my my dad
said like hey let's talk about the times
you've gotten in trouble the last few
years
it's always in the summer it's always in
that gap between football and track
season right
my little brother was allowed to quit
football it drove me crazy i called my
parents to lecture them right
well then he went to college on a cello
scholarship right so it's not like he
dropped out and just started playing
video games he
transitioned to something else but they
saw on him hey their identity wasn't in
being
a varsity parent it wasn't about them
it was about hey we know our kid well
and we think this is the right thing for
them in this season
my son and i and my wife have had fights
about violin
it's a big deal to me that my kids play
an instrument uh music ed's a huge deal
for me
and it got to where i thought i was
going to come home and my wife is going
to be sitting on the front porch with a
shovel and a cigarette and my kid was
going to have been buried out in the
yard somewhere
and we had harder and harder and harder
conversations
and so what we ultimately allowed is you
can't just quit on a random tuesday
you committed to finishing this thing
we're gonna have a recital
we're gonna put something on the
calendar that you're gonna prep for and
you're gonna have to learn the
consequences if you don't wanna practice
rock and roll we're gonna have a
practice schedule we're gonna help you
but there will be people watching this
recital and if you choose to vomit and
tank it
you're going to do it in front of a crew
if you want to
practice and be and get the support i
mean we're all in right
and so ultimately my son practiced we
were there to support my wife i i say we
what an idiot husband she did almost
95 of that and she helped him across
here got him across the finish line
and then he's taking a semester off no
violin
my marriage is better their relationship
is better and we're just taking a break
okay
so why does this matter to you we've got
to find this balance
so every parent i know is struggling
with this
with i played team sports as a kid and
most of us played team sports because
our parents wanted us to because it was
a thing for them and
we want to have this this want them to
work hard and we wanted to learn these
character things
and so the big question i want you to
answer number one is
why do you want your kid to do
gymnastics why is that important
honestly gymnastics in itself is not
important okay um
i like i was very competitive my husband
was not
i gained a lot from the team aspect
and the growing and the discipline and
all of that
um my husband is not competitive at all
um and he's very laid back he said that
with some disdain do you wish he was a
little more competitive with life
okay all right but sometimes he wishes i
was a little more chill so i guess it
evens out
okay but um for me
it's she goes out there when she's at
the practices and she does work and she
gets proud of herself
and she says i want more mom and then
she goes to a meet and if she doesn't do
well
it's like picking her up for four days
after
but instead of like doing something
about it she just sits on the couch
so have you have you all helped her draw
the link between
practice and hard work and success and
competition
we have tried um we've had these
conversations
um unfortunately she's one of these
girls who everything comes very easily
too
and so she's like well if it doesn't
just happen then it's not supposed to
happen
but we've had conversations about do you
want to continue
do you want to stop you know it's your
call
and every time she's like yeah i think
so and then we get there
and she falls down and we say well now
is a great opportunity to learn and to
grow and she's like uh maybe tomorrow
gotcha okay what do we do with this so
when you presented this to me you had
an roi investment in financially and an
roi investment in time
yes and i want you to take those off
as as anything to do with raising a
young daughter
okay okay so take those things off the
table
cost doesn't matter time is unlimited
right
which we both know neither of those
things are
what would happen to the dynamic of your
family if you took this summer
off from gymnastics
i think she would
almost be lost um when it comes to what
do i do now because it does take so much
time
um but i think eventually after a while
it might become more relaxed because
it's not the
let's go we've got to go we've got to be
here you've got to be there
and um what does she what is it what
gets her excited
what does she love
she loves planning um
i have no idea where she gets that from
by the way none at all
i bet you've already have a spreadsheet
on how this is gonna pay for college
don't you
okay so she loves planning what does
that look like yes
well she she's mapping out her future
and her plans and she's setting up her
goals and her stepping stones how old is
she
by this time she's 11. she's 11.
she's 11. she should not be mapping out
her life strategies
i'm telling you she's very very like i i
want to go here and then here and then
here
and then here uh but you realize that
that she's using grown-up words
and none of that is real none of it's
true i understand
and when her life is about an it is
fulfilling
an roi on time and money
that's how you have to formulate your
existence when you're 11.
yes has she ever heard and i'm i'm
making you feel guilty here and i'm
sorry but not sorry
okay has she ever heard you guys say hey
this takes a lot of time
or we're really busy or this is really
expensive are you sure you want to do
this
um we don't typically talk about the
financial aspect of it
um but she is 11 and she does sometimes
they will hand her like a paper that
says you know
we're going to order this leo and it
costs this much give this to mom and dad
she does see that okay um she also does
hear that because a lot of the other
parents will talk and then they talk
and sure they come out in the lobby and
then it's right there
so so here's the here's an what i would
think
is an easy solution here
and i saying easy not existential it'll
be hard
it'll be hard for you because you feel
there's a part of you that's gonna feel
like
if i don't keep my foot on the gas my
daughter's gonna turn into the
my husband who i love but come on he's
got to go jogging right
and if he would just do this i could see
so much potential in him
and he may not say it there's got to be
a part of your husband that's like
dude i just want a daughter who can
chill and laugh
and just come on man and suddenly your
daughter
whether y'all want her to or not is
absorbing both messages
and she's becoming a proxy war for you
too
and the battlefield is gymnastics right
and i'm speaking way over dramatic here
okay
your daughter knows that she loves you
and knows that she wants you to go do
these
fun things but here's the thing i want
you to come up with an alternative for
her
and see if you can talk her into it hey
what if this
this summer we just took the summer off
of gymnastics
you got to do a thing what dream
anything what would it be
girl scout i don't know what's cool so
i'm gonna say things you're gonna be
like you're such an
out of touch idiot father but i don't
know if it's girl scouts
hey daughter this summer you are
responsible for planning the weekly
schedule and we're at home
i want to see a map of it you're gonna
plan the chore list you're gonna plan
the vacation we go on
we're going to use your planning skills
and we are going you're going to get to
have
a dynamic you're going to help with the
family budget you're going to help with
these things
or um two summer camps you get
and if she comes back to you after a few
days and says i really really want to do
gymnastics that's when you can have the
hard conversation about
it doesn't feel like it feels like
you're opting out
and it feels like you don't want to do
this and we're getting to a point now
where if you don't practice gymnastics
you can get hurt really bad it's not
like soccer right
where i mean you're just running around
the ball you can fall you can get hurt
if you're not practicing hard right
and when you're 12 that's when your co
like the people around you start growing
into their bodies and they start getting
good real fast right there's gonna be an
escalation here
and so let her feel the consequences of
what you're telling us with your actions
is that you're not really in
and that's super okay and we love you we
want you to do something that brings you
joy and happiness and peace
not feel like we just got to keep making
you do this and so
let's take the summer off let's do this
thing let's play soccer you got to do a
thing
you become the family planner for the
summer we're going to pay you a dollar a
week you're the new family planner
you and your husband are gonna have to
figure out how to love each other again
because suddenly you're not gonna be
driving all over the place you're gonna
have money falling from the ceiling
because you're not paying for all this
stuff
but at the end of the day i don't want
you to feel like
if you miss this one thing it's over
it's out
it's done okay i want you to look at
three different people in my family only
one
my parents knew i need this expression
i need this interaction i need this
accountability i need this physical
exertion because they knew me well
they let me drop something else i got to
drop baseball but i had to keep doing
this
and it ended up being the right thing
and with my brother
they knew he's gonna he's gonna
transition to music this is just
not his thing he's coming home more
defeated than he is
coming home inspired he doesn't watch
football on the weekends he's not
checking the
the espn to see how the gymnasts are
doing right
but man he has a thing for music and my
brother is a prodigy he practices his
butt off and he's
he's still to this day one of the most
talented musicians i know
and then my wife who was a prodigy at
basketball and it just wasn't for her
and she went to her parents and said
i've got to be out and they said we
support you
full-on and then she transitioned to
cross-country where she was pretty good
wasn't the all-star but she's pretty
good she enjoyed it and she's a lifelong
runner now
and so this idea that 11 year old is
projecting the track of their life
whoa man slow everybody down let your 11
year old be 11.
let her play and be silly and have
outdoor adventures and go for
lazy walks with dad in fun routine
driven adventures with mom
and you all figure these things out
together
challenge her with taking the summer off
let her
exhale because the worst thing a kid can
do is feel like they are enduring
something
so that their parents will be okay and
this may mean you and your husband are
gonna have to have some hard
conversations about what do we actually
want for her what does she need what
does she not need
and your husband may have to give some
she needs some more discipline
she's got to step up and learn that she
can do hard things
and you guys are going to call it out
when it happens hey you're doing really
hard things
you can do hard things and you are going
to have to slow down a little bit and
know
you know what if she decides hey
gymnastics isn't for me
we've put a lot of money into this and
we learned a lot and it was awesome
and now we're gonna try new experiences
and we love our baby girl and she's
gonna be okay
and every parent out there ask yourself
this whose dream
is this is this our dream or is it our
kids dream
and i can tell you all the way up until
law school i would talk to students who
said i'm only here because my dad says
what i got to do
26 year olds who were burdened by their
dad's
dreams or i've met with med students i'm
only here because mom said i've got to
be a doctor
a 25 year old kid burdened with moms you
will do this
the best thing you can do for your kids
is to have an instrument in the room and
some
balls in the room and some support with
the room let them know they are tethered
in and they can try things
and when you see that spark come on then
you can lean on them
we are people who are accountable we are
people who show up for our teams we are
people who work real hard
and look at you you can do hard things
are you proud of yourself
did you put out an effort on the track
or on the on the pitch or on the
football field that you're proud of
then i'm proud of your effort right
i'm proud of your effort i'm proud that
you
overcame i'm proud that you stuck it out
now you're talking
now we're going to create a generation
of kids
who know how to work hard who know when
to say hey this one's not for me
who knows how to receive coaching and
push through hard things
but also does not get their self-esteem
from achievement and i know i'm talking
about a delicate balance here i know i
know
but that's what we're aiming for and
we're gonna get some messed wrong some
mess
right i'm gonna i'm gonna register for
my kid for jiu jitsu this summer
i'm trading him baseball in the spring
for jiu jitsu in the summer
he's not gonna like it but i want him to
go through hard things
i want him to experience that struggle
and then at the end i think he's gonna
overcome i think he's gonna begin to
love it but if he doesn't
i'm not gonna get my identity through a
11 or 12 year old jiu jitsu kid
i'm going to get my identity being a dad
who loves his son
all right thank you so much for your
call angela i love
your heart and you want to get it right
there's a lot to this after you have
this conversation with with your
daughter
after you say hey let's take the summer
off let's do something else
you're going to be the house planner
this summer we're dedicating this summer
to you
we're going to pay you for it and we
want you to join a summer camp or
girl scouts we want you to work at the
local church whatever that is
let me know how that conversation goes
i'd love to report back to our audience
on this